[Music]
what's up sam are you shooting something
or
[Music]
oh my god
get down
[Music]
you shot me sam what are you doing you
actually shot me
hey no i'm i'm real like i'm real sorry
i was just getting really into it
come on man i promise i did not even
know this was loaded i thought this was
like an airsoft thing
feeling like a real gun oh geez
i i thought this was like a t2 thing
like
look look what you made me do
wait have you actually really never seen
terminator 2 i have never seen
terminator 2. i
know the la river scene i know so many
scenes just because it's like
so in the zeitgeist it's one of the best
written films ever
my favorite scene from terminator 2 is
when arnold schwarzenegger tries to
smile maybe you could practice in front
of a mirror or something this movie came
out july
3rd 1991 in a couple months
this movie will turn 30. this was a very
revolutionary visual effects
film i know ilm was hot off the heels of
the abyss
just before going into jurassic park
this was a testing ground for a lot of
new technology
a few months ago you guys tackled tron
that was 40 years ago right
and i would say like the challenge they
faced back in the day 40 years ago was
just
just rendering that stuff out and so by
today's standards
everything can render at this point and
so now
we're going to a film that's 30 years
ago theoretically you're like oh well
this is going to be kind of easy
all of the t-1000 shots where he's just
like hanging out
and chrome looking that's kind of a
piece of cake i
don't see that as a challenge at all the
challenging stuff in this film
are the complexity of the animations now
it's no longer just like a rendering
thing
we have liquid we have like morphing
we have shape shifting we have these
really complicated animation sequences
that make this something that just
having a better computer
doesn't necessarily make this easier to
do so the shot that really sticks out to
me is the moment when
the t-1000 approaches the jail bars
and like it's nothing just slips through
them
[Music]
that little touch of just having his gun
stuck really drives home that he went
through these bars
but that's not normal you know yeah
grounds it in reality
exactly there's a couple things going on
one he approaches it in the previous
shot and gets right up next to the bars
and then it cuts away then it cuts back
to him in this static shot
where i think there's a few different
elements one we have the background
behind the bars
two we have robert patrick playing
t-1000 right here behind
three the jail bars and i think they're
three separate elements here
i'd be willing to bet that this is
projection maps
onto a 3d model of the actor yeah you
know what i bet you're right
when we say camera mapping what that is
is basically taking the
image from the camera and then
projecting it
onto a 3d model replica of patrick
stewart that's not his name patrick
robert patrick this is hard this is hard
to do i bet we can probably do this
oh i we can totally do this i want to
see if we can recreate
exactly how they did this using modern
methods
so what if you were to do this fully cg
and i was to do it with camera mapping
let's do it and so that way we can sit
down and actually compare the pros and
cons
of each effect because these days they
would just do your method
they've abandoned the old ways doing 3d
scanning
is going to be faster i'd be willing to
bet that i'm going to finish this before
you
but which one will look more real in the
end guess we'll have to find out
you know thinking about how they did all
this stuff like way back in the day
it's like it had to have taken forever
but these days not only do we have more
modern software we also have modern
efficient hardware like this loop deck
ct
and i'm going to tell you about it
because it's our sponsor for the day if
you're creative and you want to get more
into improving your workflow whether
you're a colorist an editor a sound
designer a musician
all of those apply with the loop deck so
this is actually specifically designed
to work with pretty much
any software it has api integration so
the programs actually work directly with
the hardware
it's nice it's aluminum it feels rugged
and built like i feel like i could throw
this in a backpack without ever breaking
it's got this very satisfying dial
we have a whole bunch of buttons up here
they're touch buttons and we have a
bunch of physical buttons down below
now what's actually cool about this is
you also have these dials but these
buttons here you can program to be
different
pages so you can literally map every
single
possible action in a program to one of
these touch buttons their intention i
think
is to replace the entirety of your
keyboard with
just this and when i first heard about
that honestly i was pretty skeptical i
was like nah
not gonna replace my keyboard but now
that i've actually gotten used to it and
i've been using it a little bit i
can see it so it works very well with
any adobe product premiere pro after
effects
rotate rotate scale up scale down
oh press the button to reset press the
button to reset the rotate as well
so over here in cinema 4d i actually
added some of my
own custom hotkeys to it normally it's a
little cumbersome to have to press four
keys to do an
action well it's not cumbersome to
program those four keys
and map them to a single button and
that's what i've done for all of these
octane settings i have my octane
settings pulled up oh i'm using some
materials and i want to use the node
workflow
boom note editor right there that makes
me happier
than you realize it's saving me precious
seconds
that will add up over a day meaning i
get more done
you get more done your client is happy
so if you're creative and you're looking
to you know improve your workflow here
we got links in the description check it
out
this thing is actually going to make my
life way easier and i'm definitely going
to be using this
for the foreseeable future
so we have been researching how they did
not just this shot but the whole movie
there's an
incredibly in-depth article around the
entire effects process of this movie
from beforesandafters.com
i highly recommend it it's linked down
below and the author
ian talks about this shot where the dude
goes to the jail bar cells they had to
use the software that they made called
make sticky that's what they called it
the software was originally called make
me sticky but i guess people didn't like
that so they changed the name to mick
sticky
make sticky not mcsticky that's an item
at mcdonald's you can only get after 2
a.m
basically when you have a 3d model you
have a bunch of different points they're
called vertices
a cube has eight vertices one two three
four five six
seven eight so he's describing this
process of basically taking the vertices
of a model and
gluing it to a texture so as that vertex
moves the texture moves with it
he's literally describing uvw mapping
before that was even a thing this
technology didn't even exist
they were literally like oh yeah we had
to code that from scratch
the artists were also developers at that
time there was no separation between
them
in fact t2 was the first movie at ilm
they specifically
hired a coder a developer to make the
tools
full time so that the artists could just
focus on the art
rather than also developing the tools
it's complex stuff
you know there aren't tools that are
directly built for this exact effect
you know because it's such a strange and
niche effect
so we're trying to actually replicate
the shot and with that we wanted to
replicate the field of view of the
camera
so i basically fed an image of the
original
shot into this program called f spy
which is super cool
basically you give it some straight
lines in your scene and then it
calculates the focal length of the shot
and then you can bring that information
into a 3d package like blender which i
did here and
use that to model things within the
scene to match the shot
and so i used that to make the jail bars
we are not going to build the
bars practically because what this shot
is missing in the original is proper
reflections and lighting
from him actually passing through it so
technically
our shot should be more realistic in
that regard
the goal is to kind of recreate the
original shot as close as we can
obviously
we don't have the same location we're
not gonna have the windows with the
greats and the light coming through that
uh obviously i'm not as handsome as sir
patrick stewart
but we're gonna try to recreate the
lighting so the edge light and the key
light are gonna be in the same
spot we're gonna recreate the camera
angle we're gonna digitally recreate the
jail bars so for that to really all work
there's two other things we gotta do for
the vfx side of things one
we're gonna get a nice custom hdri
so this is the old school method the way
they would have done it back then
you can just take a picture of a chrome
ball and extract the 360 image from it
and it became standard kit at ilm
for decades to come yeah and we don't
really do that anymore
i'm just taking manual pictures at
different exposures so i took one at
negative four stops
i just took one at negative 3.5 i'm
gonna take another at negative three
i'm just going to keep doing that until
i've got like a dozen different photos
at different exposures
and in photoshop i'll combine them
together into a single hdri
so for my version which is the full cgi
version we have to get a intensely high
resolution
3d scan of ren's noggin and that's going
to entail just having ren
super still while i go around him with
the dslr taking
hundreds of pictures of every little
nook and cranny and pour and
pimple he's got and then i'm going to
feed that to a computer algorithm which
uses it to reconstruct the 3d object
that you're taking a picture of
since you're doing the full scan you can
make me do whatever you want oh yeah
exactly
i can make you do whatever i want
i think peter is chewing off a very big
bite here biting off a big bite to chew
whatever analogy works best here insert
that peter is a big bite to chew
you are going to try to keep the entire
part of me
cg and that comes with all of the
uphill battles the entire industry has
faced for
decades and trying to render a
photorealistic face
here's the thing though many of those
challenges come from trying to move the
face
stretch the skin animate the expressions
but if you just have
a still expression like in this shot you
only need to get the reflections in the
sub surf and the hair looking right
and then the computer does the rest of
the work whereas
the way i intend to do this shot is
going to have all of that
baked in he has to do all of the work to
catch up to that point
you're going to have to do more manual
tweaking than i am i feel like i'm
sidestepping all that manual work and
just letting the computer do everything
and i think that's exactly why most
terminator movies since then have just
gone that route like the last couple
terminator movies that came out pretty
much anytime you see any sort of like
transformation or whatever everything
about that person or that character is
computer generated including like
basically the final finished person
but if you have a low budget or really
old you would do it with
the method i'm trying if you're really
old i mean think about it the people
working on
like t2 are like ancient now they're
like grandfathers
i am genuinely curious how this is going
to go down
this is a real actual investigation
between us right now
into the old ways of the old guard and
the new ways
of the new guard
so step one was to get the plate of us
actually trying to mimic the original t2
jailbar scene
film the plates looked all good i
imported all that in cinema 4d
used it as a background layer but also
we need a
photo scan of me for the 3d model
interaction they did that back in the
day
they had an actual laser scan of his
entire head that they used
to actually do all the morphing with and
i'm basically going to be doing the same
thing today except i'll be using peter's
photo scan of me
but i'm only going to be using the
geometry and not the textures because i
will be using my own textures
from the footage so that the 3d model
matches the real world version of me
and that's where this next step comes in
called camera mapping
i essentially just map up the camera
here line up the model and then i just
take this image
and project it onto the geometry but the
problem is that when the geometry moves
the projection doesn't move with it
so we need a way to basically stick it
to it and this is the part that has
eluded me for a very long time and it's
embarrassingly simple
all you do is right click on your
material tag go down to generate uvw
coordinates
boom done now that i've done that i can
actually move
this guy around it's me but it's
textured with the actual texture from
the background image
the moment i start whipping it around to
the other side it doesn't look real
anymore look it's because it's actually
duplicating the texture on the back side
of this
now that i literally know it was as
simple as hitting generate uvw
coordinates i can literally open my
customized commands and i'm going to
label that as
generate new dvws
i have now mapped that to my loop deck
as easy as that so now anytime i want to
do a projection thing i can literally
like hit the button and i'm good to go
yeah so the effect i've actually been
trying to get to is how do i distort
this mesh here i can use the grab tool
and literally just grab
my nose here
oh man i can now back this through the
poles here you notice how the jail bars
are
actually interacting with my face
exactly how it would with real geometry
that's the magic of this method but the
challenge i have now
is correctly deforming the model as i go
through
the bars here because i actually gotta
do the distortion of it frame by frame
and then it's a matter of rendering it
out and then recompositing it so that it
meshes with the original footage
flawlessly
i'm not gonna lie this has been a little
on the stressful side
and i needed some inspiration i was i
was about to give up that is until
[Music]
now
i literally made a macro on this thing
that
opens a url launches it in a new browser
and then waits a moment and then double
clicks on the mouse to maximize it to
full screen
i could have rick rolled you but i
didn't because i needed the inspiration
to not give up here i'm hoping to have a
finished shot by the end of the day
that's that's my goal for today i might
have to hit that button a few more times
so working with this photo scan has been
a bit troublesome progress has been slow
but we're working through it
3d scans have just inherent problems
that come with them like
when you try to scan hair it doesn't
really work it comes in a solid
object and when you try to render that
out it just looks like somebody has a
lump
of sculpted clay that's painted to look
like hair and so what you have to do
is i took the scan of wren and i
smoothed it out a little bit with a
sculpting brush and then i actually had
to
smooth over his hair completely and then
pat it down
into the form of a head and so now i
have this really weird looking model of
ren
where he has a smooth overhead that's
definitely not his head shape
anyways for the hair i used blender's
hair system and i actually
grew out the hair so it looks like one
big straight afro
and then i had to ask ren how he styles
his hair because
i have to take this hair pointing in all
directions and actually style it to look
like ren's hair
and so in blender i had to go through
with the comb tool literally
and give him a little haircut once i was
done with the big hair on the top of his
head i had to add the little tiny hairs
some stubble on his lip and his jawline
i added back in some eyebrows
because you know any hair you scan in
just is not usable you got to create new
hair for your skin
and then after that i added some skin
texture because there are certain
properties
in cgi that make it look realistic and
you use what are called
bump maps and reflection maps in 3d
models which are basically
images that tell the computer which
parts of the bottle should be shiny and
which parts the model should be bumpy
and with a 3d scan you don't get any of
that inherently so you have to make that
stuff from scratch
and so basically i had to kind of like
paint where the oil would be on his face
a little bit
and i had to add some micro bumps for
the skin and that helped a little bit
catching the light and making the skin
look a little bit more real and the last
element
that is the cherry on top is subsurface
scattering that's the thing where you
take a flashlight and you shine it
through your hands
or the back of your ear and you see the
red and the light coming through
it's basically just light entering a
surface and scattering around
and coming out the other side and so
that's what i added to the face so
the skin doesn't look just like complete
plastic you know you get
some of the light bleeding it as for the
actual distortion of the face going
through the bars i tried something
different which i've never actually
tried before i used a
lattice object it's basically a giant
cage which you bind to your mesh which
is inside of it
and then when you move a part of the
cage it moves the part of the mesh
that's closest
to that part of the cage i just went
through the sequence animating these
having it bounce back and jiggle a
little bit that was animated manually
the cool thing about doing it in cg is
that you really get the accurate look of
the light
penetrating the hair and the hair
bending around the
bars the downside to this is getting a
likeness of a person
is very difficult and i would be staring
at my computer screen and i'd be like
yeah this looks pretty good and then i
would look over a red and be like
god damn it this doesn't look like him
at all and so i just spent a lot of time
dialing in that look but besides that
i'm very happy with how it turned out
and i think it looks pretty sweet
okay we have finished our visual effects
shots here we have finished our pieces
to
varying levels of quality yeah it was
surprisingly challenging you'd think
that having all this modern tech it
would make it
really straightforward but i guess
that's never still very hard yeah all
right so
let's go ahead and look at the actual
morph shot that i made last night at 2am
damn dude this is the way to do it you
think so yeah
so what are your first thoughts when you
see this this looks amazing i mean it's
obviously you a big problem i had with
mine was that it it looks like a weird
uncanny valley version of ren i don't
think if i was watching this as a viewer
and it was part of a movie i don't think
it would
faze me uh the only thing that's kind of
bugging me is the
you were saying like the key framed
stretching and stuff it could be
animated a little bit smoother but it
totally works
i have not seen what you've made yet and
i'm very intrigued yeah this one i'm
like
i'm like simultaneously really happy
with this and also it's like kind of
really weird
whoa oh my god this has your classic
style written all over it
so i'm really happy with everything in
this
except your likeness for starters it's
really hard to create an exact 3d
replica of somebody like freaking star
wars couldn't even do it
it's really tough yeah and the problem i
was having was that this
mesh that i got of your head was so
incredibly high resolution that it was i
couldn't even work with it i had to down
res it a little bit
and that caused some artifacts around
your eyes it looks like there's a bit of
like a geometry bump right over my right
bottom eyelid there so there's a few
things that you've done here
that really elevated the shot from the
original that i didn't do first you
added some camera motion
uh the camera's actually pushing in a
little bit over the course of the shot
uh you added some character movement to
me
like my eyes are moving my head's moving
a little bit and on top of that the
actual distortion
has ripples to it that was tough it
definitely came down to a lot of
fidgeting with the animation and the key
frames it's it's all keyframed
the fact that you literally made the
hair from scratch
is like so high level and you can really
see it there as the hair like literally
like
bends around like parting of the winds
that is something
neither i or ilm were able to do totally
and it's like this
method is far from perfect but i think
that's one aspect
that would play into the perfect way to
do this what would we do differently
to combine our powers in my opinion i
think we would do it
full cg except for the face for the face
we would use your method
which is the projection mapping onto the
face so then you don't have any weird
likeness issues but you can still get
the hair and the
simulation and all the nice new
technology that we have
to use so has this given you a bigger
appreciation for what they did back in
the day
definitely i still have no idea how they
did
the liquid moving around the bar and
reforming
ours just like stretches back out it
doesn't reform into a mesh
i feel like the tools they had when
doing this shot were specifically
capable of doing it the way they did and
the software we use today
is very broad it's supposed to be able
to do everything and anything
as opposed to being really good at just
this one thing freaking shout out to all
the original artists who work on this
shot and
pioneered software just to make this and
yeah it was very groundbreaking and
kudos to all of y'all who
figured it out so for this video i tried
to get in touch with doug
smythe i think is his name he worked on
this shot if you are seeing this doug
and you want to chat with us we would
love to have you do a segment about this
on visual effects artists react hit us
up
well guys if you liked this video and
you want to see more deep dives into
older vfx to see how they can be remade
with modern technology
leave a comment down below if you think
there's a movie that we can recreate an
effect from
and maybe improve upon it or maybe
discover that hey
they were geniuses back then yeah that's
kind of what happened today
[Applause]
okay like now look at him
look at him he's not coming back look
look what you made me do
don't see that every day
oh my god